[Music]
April 2nd as the music continues to play
Sims goes online to look up more
material on a guy he will roast on
Wednesday for challenging the
environment so stay tuned episode 160
Sims one minute to tear apart a guy one
minute it's gonna take more than one Oh
everybody out there let's just look up
Stephen Goddard G OD dar de also has a a
ke Tony Heller that's when you know a
person's bad learn about the environment
from a guy that's a master's in
electrical engineering so that's what
we're gonna learn on Friday that coming
up for Wednesday so guys hello and
welcome as always we have a jam-packed
show because the NFL no longer sleeps it
is 365 it is 52 weeks a year it is seven
days a week we have a lot of topics we
are going to be using the out of left go
field hat to pick our topics today ok
but first I want to say if you're
watching on YouTube he is a matching one
no just for me just one hat oh I had a
website caught out a left go field and
yeah just one yeah website it was like a
blog it was a tumblr remember and you
thought tumblr was a gymnastics website
I don't know you lost me at I had a
website ok I stopped listening jeez what
a dork I'm shoe should i watch film all
day and I don't understand anything goes
oh but speaking of websites you were on
the mm QB this morning oh saying that
you believe that this draft class was a
little bit overrated that Josh Allen was
the guy and Lamar has a huge ceiling
you're very concerned pretty much all
the stuff that you've been talking about
on the pike I usually don't give away
free information that it's not set here
first so yeah I mean Peter King and I we
have a good relationship
I'm just curious does he call you and go
I need some I need you to fill some
space on mmq I think he's a little bit
of a listener to the podcast at times
yes hey Peter any a also we're gonna
have mom we got to have him on here
before the dry would like that right
before the draft I just think he could
add little side notes and I think
formation er for the whole league I like
you on the draft oh wow I get that but I
also think he can give us some in
site information that I won't be able to
give us or things like that I'm like
what are you talking about with Dorsey
right he just has connections throughout
the league through a long history of
being around it that he's gonna know
something's that I don't care who I am
or who my dad is
that I'm not gonna know he's got great
relationships that way sorry so before
we get to picking topics out of the Hat
I want to talk about what he said in the
article which is that he's hearing from
a friend of John Dorsey that dorsey's
leaning towards Allen at one and say
Quan at four is the first time that I've
heard Josh Allen being mentioned for the
Browns it's bend Arnold Arnold Arnold
and seeing as how Sims doesn't take in
any media at all I guess you didn't read
this what do you think of Allen and
Barkley no I make sense to me make sense
to us it definitely makes sense that's I
have heard the rumors that they were
maybe hotter on Allen than Darnell just
three NFL people but I did not know that
through the media it makes sense just
from my first thing where I connect the
dot is really okay so Hugh Jackson I
mean he liked quarterbacks like Carson
Palmer now he's dropped a John Kaiser
right right and so I mean I didn't think
the Shawn was very talented but he does
like the bigger type of quarterback and
then I think the other part of the
equation there you gotta think of is
Todd Haley - I mean he did just come
from Big Ben Roethlisberger he is from
that Bill Parcells school of coaching -
where I do think they value a bigger
type of quarterback and yeah to me at
this point it yeah I mean he's slam dunk
number one for me I don't really have
any argument about that at this point
you're dead set on yes I am I'm dead set
on my five I really am I question though
was I've also read that the Browns as I
fix us microphones excuse the audio as
the Browns I've also read that they also
really like Bradley Chubb right and the
thought of matching him up with Miles
Garrett so my question is would you
rather have the dynamic duo of Allen and
Berkeley on offense or the dynamic duo
of Garrett and Chubb with a quarterback
on defense yeah whoo it's a really good
question I I think you know it always
depends on the players themselves and I
just think I value say qualm Barkley
higher than a Bradley Chubb I really
like Bradley job I feel like Bradley
Chubb is the best pass rusher in this
group but I don't think he's the best
pass rusher we've seen the last three
four years right I don't even know if
he's top three no I don't know right
right I mean
clowny he's not cool man no that mean
that right off the bat I think he's in
that class now he's really good yes I
think the fact that there's no other big
pass rushers in this class magnifies him
and magnifies everything better fast yes
where one position group is shallow and
one guy and I think it's what's gonna
happen to quit Nelson but I think quit
Nelson is that good he is that good
quitting Nelson I mean we'll get into
some of these edge pass rushers and Oh
Lyman over the next three weeks before
the draft and really break them down but
yet Nelson I mean come on left go you
know I saw him in person all year long
and I'm solvent person that I was like
you're bigger than I thought yeah yeah
he's just a big square block of New
Jersey meanness he's awesome and what's
funny is he's like a really nice kid
yes yeah when he gets out there you
could see it so I don't think people
realize tonight we're recording this
Monday it is the national championship
game for college basketball about
there's gonna be Villanova taking on
Michigan who do you got
I've got Nova babies all the way I like
Michigan the story's cool on that but
yeah I'm no ball I don't know if I'm
staying up for the game I'm gonna stay
up and J right I mean come on is there a
more handsome well-dressed head coach in
the sport this is also a big night for
the NFL yeah and I would say for the
last three years of doing the podcast
we've tried to talk about this in some
way and mother hen mother had a producer
Josh let's talk about this but guess
what we've grown as a podcast you talked
about it yeah the national championship
in college basketball is a celebration
for NFL players around the NFL it is
what are they celebrating Chris they are
celebrating that their ass is about to
be on the clock for a drug testing it's
your last night to get it in puff puff
give or give it a pump up don't give and
hog it to yourself cuz you're gonna be
giving it away for a while so you told
me this three years ago and I didn't
realize that because of the way the
league schedule works one month from
today is the start of May that's when
we're getting into like chilly the day
is 4/20 now I literally think they've
made 4/20 the day of officially drug
testing and you you believe and you
you've experienced it oh yes that the
college basketball championship people
believe that's when you stop smoking
weed and that's when you'll pass tests
getting up you're cutting it a little
close even at this point
oh but nobody's expecting the drug
testers to be in the building the first
day you walk in right so you're kind of
calling the bluff of the NFL there you
know right now yeah what is it March 2nd
so it's only 18 days if you have a high
body fat percentage you're gonna be
risking the chance of not getting it out
of your system and but if you lean and
but if you're lean and mean right and
you're ripped up like would you guys get
together yes I mean it's it's horrible
it's a horrible day yes what do you mean
because you just dread it the last two
weeks as a player gone man this is I'm
coming down to my last few days I've
been able to smoke so this is not a
celebration no it's it's like a
celebration and also like it's more like
porn one out for the homies right it was
a fun office fun now we got to sit here
and we can't touch this stuff until we
get tested so many of our listeners
favor football players might be home
tonight watching the basketball their
tweets seem a little nonsensical so when
you're watching the game tonight if
you're seeing people being like Michigan
more like Sh Michigan if you like
Michigan State's good at basketball be
like oh they're stoned it's are coming
down the end alright so and that and who
taught you that well I you know I just I
think my rookie year in the NFL was one
of those things you kind of learned in
the locker room but we're talking about
man we're coming to the end they got
that test coming soon we gotta get gotta
get clean and this is the unofficial
end this is the unofficial it I always
would have you know a few guys over we
were on the drug program I'm just gonna
that's okay fine I was in the drug
program for six out of my eight years of
the NFL career that's fine to put that
out there yes so I am so if four people
want to go it was a good at quarterback
because he was stolen the whole time no
I was not stoned because I was always in
the drug program you're right if you're
on the drug who means that you were
clean I was clean as hell they're the
ones you gotta watch out for yes and
that was a habitual line stepper I mean
that was a habitual like wow I could
squeeze one more day and no and then but
you know what I don't know if we've ever
really had this conversation when you
talk about the drug testing program it's
miserable to be a part of in the NFL you
get in it I did push the limit a little
bit right and then got one of the early
tests like
like you want the early test yes so for
people that don't realize if you're not
in the drug program we've talked about
this a number of times as soon as you
get tested and cleared they don't test
you again until next C so street drugs
and you get tested in April or May right
so that you're good for the entire
offseason exactly right if you get
tested in November you're going or when
it's August August is they have to do it
some now at some point between April and
August you have to be tested for street
drugs right yeah so yeah there was many
a times where you know let's just say
the years I wasn't in the drug program
where you go and you go off clean I'm
clean and you're going my I hope they
get me the first day at training camp
you're rooting for them they're still
not here
yes gosh damn it's three weeks in the
training camp layers like walking by the
guy being like you'll test me next what
I would try to pay them I knew that I
wouldn't do that but when you were in
the facility and you knew the drug
tester was there let's say May or
whatever else you were definitely gonna
go by and go were you confused like I
was when you first got there though
about people being excited to be drug
tested early on I remember when I met
that player in Oakland I don't know if
guys say no say his name okay but we
were hanging out and he was like I got
tested
yeah oh man that sucks he was like are
you kidding me he's like no I'm free
release you talk about like the drug
program is really intense it's miserable
to call them before you go anywhere they
watch you while you pee right you can be
tested up to three times a week I
believe I mean it's it's it's I believe
ten times a month they can test you and
you're definitely guessing once a month
yeah you're definitely get once a week
and of course they're gonna throw curve
balls at you in some weeks you might get
to two in a week maybe even three in a
week maybe three days in a row because
they might go oh let's see maybe he
thinks he's gonna get it long can we
talk about the time I caught the second
time or is that two months no it's okay
I'm just gonna say like I never realized
that you lost four games x one year I
did I'm being totally honest here I do
it alright fine are you cool with it I'm
cool it's fine I yeah I one year in
Tampa Bay I was in the drug program and
I took a chance I did I got home from a
preseason game and the guys were hanging
out and I was like damn man that looks
fun and I I took a few hits and I ended
up getting in the program again yes and
I lost four games did he test you like
the next day it was it was a great man
I'm busted
but yes you lost four games X because of
that man good thing it was my rookie
contract there was nothing bigger than
big money my question is yes when you
know that you're playing for free yeah
doesn't matter
never factors in not at all but after
the gate like cuz when do you get the
game checks yeah I mean it depends on
the team but you're usually like what
every other game maybe right so like I'm
a Tuesday so everyone's in the locker
and they're looking at their checks and
you're just like all right nothing
there's no nimble open night you still
humble I just still think it's crazy you
guys don't get direct deposit I do but
you're also gonna get a piece of paper
to go this has been deposited into your
account right so you're gonna have
something no matter what but yeah just
real long story short the drug program
miserable you can be tested all the time
they can come to your house how many
times was I on the way to see a movie
with my wife really and then they call
and there I was like damn honey I mean
they wouldn't meet you at the movie
theater no I think we got to go back
like because you have a time once they
call you the time limit starts let me
ask you haven't gone through that right
did it did it make you go I don't want
to do this like I'm gonna like I'm not
gonna do the drugs it's just not worth
it yeah I mean no obviously I did not
learn my lesson completely there I did
not that's just what I am I'm a little
bit stubborn that way how long does it
take to get out of it oh so it depends
on your behavior and if you fail test
when you're in there but once you're in
you're in for basically two years
straight right Wow
yeah so you're in two years straight
like you said if I went home to New
Jersey I'd have to call the NFL League
offices and go hey I'm going to New
Jersey I'm gonna be at this address yeah
you can reach me at this number and
they're gonna come get you was it the
same guy there's gonna be pull your
pants down below your knees I mean
totally below your knees underwear pants
ball your knees take your shirt off like
not just like raise it up has to be
completely naked on the top and yes
they're gonna sit there
and watch you very strictly pee into the
cup
shoutout to Ontario Smith who probably
caused all that I guess he had the
wisdom it wasn't a nursery yes but my
fear whenever I've pee in a cup right is
that it's gonna overflow that's always
my fear if you ever repeating a Gatorade
bottle when you're like on a road trip
and you're like oh god it's gonna hit up
like I would have that fear in front of
him yeah well I think you mean you're
doing it in front of a toilet hopefully
to where you're not Oh wasn't like in
your kitchen no I wasn't like hey honey
the mess returns are almost ready hold
on I'm always closing out here the
dictionary squozen ah yes to squeeze on
all of you into my deep dark secrets
there believes that dark I don't think
it is either I don't care I'm not
ashamed of it I know like I worry about
like Bleacher who are gonna be like are
you sure it's okay but I don't care I'm
fine I don't know if I'm trying to be
transparent and I don't think people
hear any of this okay and that's why I
think it's interesting to me cuz I
haven't heard anything right I haven't
heard it they definitely have write it
right wait so did you become friends
wick was it the same guy that would come
was most times easy Tampa representative
yeah right there's there's like three
guys in a rotation usually for every
team they're like X FBI agents right so
they're very into the letter of the law
and there's a practice you ever did you
make jokes you you think some of them
were cool some of them were all business
but you could talk to them like human
beings or you'd be like hey you know I'm
I'm at the store I'll be there in 20
minutes just relax okay I'll be here
whatever have a close call didn't get
there I can't say that I did I was
always pretty good because you can't
even enjoy yourself like just like okay
he's here let me go back and do it real
you ever crack a joke like I'm taking
your shirt off and you're like what the
question was did you no I did not if you
could make one right now all right are
you ready to do this ready I don't want
to host today okay I'm giving up my host
duties so I'm gonna put it in the Hat so
that simms will actually be controlling
what topics were talking about and you
know like that last one Sims like if you
would have nailed that joke yes I would
have oh man oh man the audios not turned
on if you would have nailed that joke
well he was still not turned on stymied
she doing this and [ __ ] with me
no they left the control no it's not
working how is that possible Godley Oh
jolly gee George can you hear it
I think you're lying to me Steinmetz all
right here it is we have three main
topics that we're gonna put in here the
first one is draft quarterbacks that is
your specialty the second one is they'll
hold out amigos there's that and then
last one is coach versus star player
battles Sims reach in and on the count
of three you're gonna pull it out and
read it
well first topic that we will be doing
on Sims and left go out of the Hat is
grab the one I didn't want him coach
first star player battle
bum ba-bum all right that's awesome
yes all right so hold on to that yes why
didn't you want to pick this one I just
saw it all right so guess what reach it
again and figure out which one we're
talking about first there are three
coach versus player battles reach in
there you're funny and the first one is
Jim Mora junior verse Josh the rosin one
rosin rosin one yeah Jim Mora came out
there a few weeks ago and said he'd take
darn 'old over rosin and then he tried
to backtrack with Peter King What did he
say
he was like look look the kid is a
millennial he needs to be challenged
intellectually so he doesn't get bored
he needs to know why
Millennials once they know why they're
good here's where it got dicey he goes
if you can hold his concentration level
and focus only on football for a few
years he will set the world on fire
wow that's stolen under the radar shot
there the number-one knock on Rosen is
does he love the game so when you say if
you can keep him focused on football
from a few years you're like oh so he's
only gonna focus on football for a few
years it's just by the way I looked back
the last time Jim Mora he said something
about miles Jack where he people were
asking him it should miles Jack have
left so earlier I had Morris response
was I don't know if they're gonna have
enough tape on him right right
Mora used to be an analyst yes and I
think when you used to be an analyst
like I think Herm Edwards is gonna have
this problem too
you're used to just saying things and
because these guys were not popular
analysts there their stories didn't
there their comments didn't become
stories but when you're the coach of the
kid it becomes a story the Millennial
thing to me it's like or you have to
explain to him why I'm just tired of
punishing kids for being intelligent
agreed I mean smart that's a positive it
is I mean listen the whole conversation
the way he started it out you know why
we're talking about this in the first
place to say that oh you know the
Cleveland Browns they should take Sam
Darnell then his makeup must fit the
situation better I mean that was a shot
to Josh Rosen even though even though he
might have been trying not to get his
quarterback to go to cleave hi I've
heard that but again I mean is he gonna
call all the other 31 teams to tell them
that or is he gonna just let it be
because none all other teams that don't
know Jim nor junior are gonna go well
damn Jim Moore juniors tell me to pick
the quarterback from the crosstown rival
over the guy that he spent time with
yeah and we know they had their little
spats here and there right so this is
where it's confusing to me Jim Moore a
junior a head coach right and probably
wants to coach again I think it's uh man
nothing's better for your career than
have the number one pick on your resume
at the quarterback position oh look this
guy he knows how to scout quarterbacks
he can develop them to always a
defensive coach but he still knows what
they look like it's like when you were
looking at schools and the coach at
Tennessee had worked with Peyton David
Cutcliffe and you went I want to work
with a guy that's worked with Peyton
exactly right I want to work at the guy
that's worked with Morgan he's really
hurting himself by saying that and not
supporting his guy I think he was that
supportive of Hundley either hmm I don't
know I can't remember exactly but yeah I
could save from Josh Rosen and miles
Jack he's wrong because the guy the guys
got good recruiters apparently Oh
do you really think it's gonna hurt
Rosen all of this no
don't realize I heard think it hurts
more I'm more than anything no it's just
yeah you're right it's gonna in the end
of the day it's gonna hurt him more it
feeds into the Rosen narrative more
though it's just one more voice you saw
the video with Rosen and Aaron Rogers I
didn't watch it what I said well I know
watch it later it's just I look at him
and I go oh so so Aaron Rodgers they're
talking it was an NFL Network thing
right and Aaron Rodgers Rosen's ask him
how do you keep interested in practice
and you know Aaron Rodgers is going look
man you got to find ways to challenge
yourself because I'm in year 13 and it
gets a little bit boring and so Rodgers
was saying I'll drop back and I'll see
how long I could go before I look and
then I throw and Rosen was like really
appreciating that and but that's what
they say about Rodgers you know Rodgers
is too smarter he's a little bit
different right it's guys we need to
learn how to celebrate talent I always
take it back to the Celtics two years
ago when they took jaylen Brown at three
kid at a Cal had like a big score on his
SATs everyone said he's too smart at all
if he loves basketball right kids
fantastic course he's fantastic
I know it's where the people get too
nitpicky about this and yet brains and
individualism and outside the box
thinking especially in football more
times than not is looked down upon
there's just it's it's that military
mentality that something in the NFL that
I know that the fans and us agree it's
just it's not good not good if you
listen to bad they start hissing ready
listen
[Music]
you stink so bad that I have to come up
with a new sound all right back to this
back to coaches versus star players
uh-oh and the second big thing they're
in there
is Jonathan gird inverse market king
Jonathan Gruden versus mark cat king
mark cat King was let go and everyone
was saying oh that you know his salary
dropped down and then it came out that
no Jon didn't really like his
personality I went and there's a clip
online that you should check out of
Marquette King doing an interview this
offseason at the NFL Network wearing a
crown a robe with a staff and in it he's
talking about how he's the king he's
like he's a personality yes he's out
there yes and they're like hey did you
go and talk to Gruden and he paused and
he was like no they didn't they didn't
invite me up there or anything like that
and you could tell it was like a little
weird and contentious this is clearly
Gruden's team and all that right you
know the guy yeah what do you think
about him getting rid of the putter I
think he's a very good putter he is a
very good punter but just knowing Jon
Gruden he doesn't want that strong of a
personality add punter
he just doesn't I don't think he wants
to deal with it I'm sure he's heard
stories maybe about him that he is a
little bit of a handful whether it's TV
in the locker room whatever it may be
but there was something uncomfortable
about him and I know that Jon Gruden is
not gonna let a punter be the focal
point of any attention for his football
team going forward so is there any
position that has less leverage like
like he's getting paid 3 million right
right so he's a very highly paid honor
right he's a very vocal Potter obviously
we support that like I support guys and
into valid visuality and all that but in
terms of the position where I feel like
the NFL could just say I'm going in a
cheaper direction I feel like those guys
get eliminated so quick I do but still
there is great value and good punters I
mean we know that we do I mean you look
at you know some of the the great
punters in the NFL their ability to
change field position is special the way
they can pin you inside the 10-yard line
but I'd also think that Jon Gruden
and you know probably doesn't want him
doing the moonwalk just because he
knocked the ball inside the 20-yard line
surprising to you or no it's not at all
I mean he just never gave the time of
the day to really any kickers or punters
in and he's a lot like a lot of us
football fans are just like are you
damned kicker upon early we're done with
special teams get the hell off the
practice field well some people said
that when he covered those games he
would complain every time market King
would do something I wonder why though
wonder if there's something there more
that he knows about then then I mean it
is a very nice just a grinding he could
be right he's got rid of Crabtree yep
he's gotten rid of Marquette King yeah
two very vocal guys in the locker room
right is that a good thing yes I mean
it's not the type of vocal guy he like
he's not afraid of vocal in the locker
room but he's only wanted to be a vocal
guy that he knows is more on his terms
maybe and just know that his hearts in
the right place and you know I don't
know about Market Market King enough but
I know Crabtree is certainly dicey from
from that's now the other thing the
other thing that caught that market King
did was he posed for a picture faking
pulling off Aqib Talib chain at the Pro
Bowl geez yeah you didn't see that no I
did not no yeah yeah so I think I
understand what you're saying is I think
when you have a change of the guard look
we've all done this you're setting the
tone you've been in your office's guys
out there women out there and and the
new boss comes in and they give this
rousing speech and someone leans over
and goes yeah right yeah he just doesn't
want the yeah rights in there sure and I
feel bad for Marquette King but I also
understand if I'm Jon Gruden and I got
one or two years in Oakland and then I
have to get to Vegas that I don't
necessarily need the opinion guy at
punter no he doesn't mind he doesn't
want to risk any of that but if he
brings back Shane LeClair that's just
absurd because obsessive [ __ ] like but
yeah I mean I think what you said is is
correct and he is I mean even with
Marshawn Lynch
I mean he's you know made a lot of
comments that he needs to be better this
year we need to depend on him or whether
it's Amari Cooper he's not being shy of
sharing his thoughts to the media
because he hasn't been able to meet with
his dad will change the first day right
so today's the first day the message out
there that way so all of the teams that
have new coaches this is the
say they actually get to be with
everybody oh man look what is Gruden
speech on that first day I think he was
going for 85 plays in his first 30
minute walk through that was his goal he
told me what yes 85 plays oh wait so
this isn't like orientation like it's
not like here at bleacher report where
someone new comes in they go here's your
desk now we're gonna do it trust me I do
some of that but then they're like all
right hurry up get your ass ready we're
going out in the field for our first run
and them our lift and then we're gonna
meet you on the field for a 30-minute
walk through right after that hurry up
nice to meeting all you guys 85 plays do
you remember the first time you saw
Gruden run a practice oh yeah I just
couldn't get over the pace of it I was I
was amazed by that's what he does now
he's like almost the opposite of New
England we're Bella I mean I like Bella
check is gonna go ten plays here's ten
plays perfect and we're not moving on
until we get it right
Gruden goes no here's I want to see how
much you guys can handle how much you
can retain the next day when we do it
again yeah and I just want to see
everybody move and do a little bit of
everything five a lot 85s a lot so how
many would josh mcdaniels haven't done I
mean Joshua's be more like the Bella
check way but like when we had those
30-minute walk throughs and it was
Josh's first year yeah we would get
through I'm gonna say maybe 40 to 50
what about Jeff Fisher and Tennessee
yeah same thing I mean if Jeff Fisher
was actually not even that way we
weren't gonna be worried actually
necessarily more about plays we were
gonna work on more on fundamental stuff
like know he was a little different that
way we're gonna throw and catch Lyman
we're gonna do hand drills it was that
kind of way yes the way he is right like
we're gonna be bigger right we're gonna
be faster we're gonna be stronger color
check is almost like a blend of both
he's kind of that old-school like we're
gonna do it right we're gonna work on
fundamentals but he's also like okay I
gotta you know I got these 12 plays I
want Patricia what do you think Patricia
is gonna be like Patricia will be more
like Belichick - they're gonna go out
there and they're gonna work on cover -
for the first four days and the team's
gonna be like what the [ __ ] are we are
we gonna do cover two and he's gonna go
well no we haven't done it perfect yet
so when we do that I'll give you cover
three it's gonna go from what do you
think Gruden's first speech is gonna be
like to the team what do you think he's
gonna really like focus on oh just I
feel like he's gonna give a speech
energy do you love football
you gotta love this man I mean he loves
man you love it you love it
hey you love football hey hey hey Derek
Derek Derek I mean do you [ __ ] love
this play or what I mean do you [ __ ]
love it I love it yes see I think I
think he's going to give a speech that's
very Rader centric and very out Davis
Center oh he's all in on the Raiders let
me just tell ya I read the article but
from SL price like a few weeks ago about
him there and how al Davis still has
like they haven't changed all Davis's
office at all like the last there's a
play still on there and Gruden goes in
goes maybe come on man it's got Louis
the game he loves the game and I think
he's gonna get up there and he's gonna
go I want you to look at your helmet man
I want you to see the radio man how
would you know who you are like that's
good that's what I feel like his speech
is gonna be today yeah his speech day is
about the Raider Oakland's losing his
team man what are they gonna have in a
god man that I tell you at the calm I've
at the owners meeting that I told him he
should wear a patch on his eye and coach
his team like that no cuz he's like man
he's like you know oh who's a special
place to me I had kids born in Oakland
and you know I did it's special to me
and I go I know I go you're made for the
Raiders he goes happen I really am
I said yeah I'm like I mean and there
was like there was like two other guys
and I was like it you're so made for him
I've even said I don't know if you heard
me I said you should wear the patch on
your ideas he is he was do you think he
was serious when he said I might I might
no he's not seriously I might alright
last one
it is coach player battle it's the
Belichick battles in the NFL all right
so this one was two ways it first
started off with Belichick being
frustrated with Gronk
so they weren't sure that tight end was
all in because of course if you watch
cron keys dancing with Shaquille O'Neal
and then he's like taking his shirt off
and then he's doing st. Patty's Day and
then someone says are you gonna retire
and he says I'm going to the 69 hours
like that's what he does right and then
also he come
mented he posted for Amendola yes this
was the big one right and underneath a
picture of Amendola he wrote a lot of
words but for them were be free be happy
they were a free and happy were in all
caps and it went to the storyline that
Lane Johnson said where he was like
there they run by fear up there not by
happiness yeah well now it's also coming
out that Grunk is frustrated with
Belichick according to espn.com
he's pretty certain he's coming back I
can't believe we're still talking about
whether or not he's coming back right
now but here's the catch he's only
willing to play as long as Tom Brady's
on the team my question to you is this
yeah Tom Brady he's in the locker room
guy comes down and goes crunk coach
wants to see you and he goes up there
and Gronk knocks on the door and he
walks in and it's Belichick and Gronk
what is that conversation like between
those two humans because I have a guess
well yeah it's it's gonna be bill
controlling the conversation do you
think Bill's gonna meet with him yeah
it's simple okay so don't control the
conversation yeah and he's in and I just
think really he's just gonna explain
where he's at bill is gonna be bills
actually way better in these situations
than I think people realize he's just
gonna lay it all out there
yeah people expect him to be the way is
with the media right this is not gonna
be like that he's just gonna lay it out
there without any emotion
he's just didn't tell him what's
concerning him and where's your mind at
yeah and he's gonna let go just want to
know the truth up and he's gonna let
Gronk concoction--
see that's why I think how it goes as
Gronk walks in and he sees Belichick
right and I feel like Gronk his head
goes immediately down he's like I'm so
sorry I just feel like he's gonna turn
into the QB like I'm sorry dad like I
was just being Gronk you know just being
gruff he's not gonna say sorry and
Bill's not gonna expect him to say sorry
bills not Bill's not that like that much
of a dictator right but listen up there
in New England this is real I mean come
on I mean I mean you know you've had me
tell you how many pyres have left their
coaches they leave the
that just go man I made it out I made it
out alive I mean there's nobody in the
NFL I talked to when a you know I talk
about my shorts career as a coach in the
NFL or being involved in an organization
they call you did start at the worst
place possible and I'm like hey you're
right I did you know just for me
grinding day to day no fun atmosphere
yeah that's New England sorry
that's the price that come for five
Super Bowls and eight appearances that's
that's the thing is he always gives the
speech in training camp and all that and
I Tom Crean actually wrote about this in
Sports Illustrated Guren yeah no cream
like the actual coach watch it he got to
go see a Patriots practice right and it
was like a training camp day and he said
that bill kept saying we are working
harder than everybody else right now
at the end of the year the fruits of
your labor will come through right and
Bill thinks that people should realize
that all the time yes and he doesn't
realize that unlike himself people like
to do things outside of work node and
they like to have families like they
have a life because in Bill's mind why
don't not why don't you just work this
hard all the time and you can celebrate
and relax later realize he's a coach and
he's a different animal than a player
it's just a different animal I want him
to come out at us and like a training
camp thing and you know how he is like
his little speeches right like no days
off yeah I want him to go football is
fun that's all the fun you need football
is fun
no that's what I'd like winning is fun
for them that's all they care about
listen he's some people up there call
him the soleus wonder right maybe he's
soulless I mean he just what I you were
my quarterback for 20 years of your cut
they said the same stuff about Bill
Walsh no doubt about it but I also would
say this we're like just it again in my
time there and even with Josh McDaniels
this will hold true of course because he
did things like in New England we did
the least amount of team camaraderie
stuff right
gotcha speak to anything when I see Dan
Quinn he's got the whole team carrying a
log or I see like these guys they go on
a trip somewhere you mean in the am
bright like oh you know I'll make today
easy maybe well we'll have a water
balloon fight at the end of practice or
see it on Hard Knocks everywhere there's
like a nice like that pole exactly right
or we're gonna go
the movies there go bowling today we're
not gonna practice the second practice
I'm gonna keep you out the heat we're
all gonna go bowling as a team and have
fun have a little camaraderie and
buildings that's always so that just
never happens in doing it's not even a
topic of conversation was never even on
the radar I mean there was never one day
I'll not even except this is the only
thing I can speak to us fun it was the
last day of OT A's and he made the
defensive tackles runned a four by 100
relay they had to run around the field
in a certain time if they broke the time
there was no last ot a practice and did
they do it and they did and it was Vince
Wilfork and the last leg and oh he was
hilarious Vince can go when he opens up
and that thing is that he's got nine
bowling balls for a belly but when he
opens up he can really get imagining the
slow motion on the beach with what's the
like rocky and Apollo Creed you know
what's the movie where they're running
on the beach in slow motion Denton and
yes Kerry to fire
Terry it's a fire thank you a hundred
percent that's how I imagine like your
team be like one of those things
especially up there because you don't
ever get time off or days off where they
were like oh we can get get out of here
you know a few hours early and not have
to go to practice and watch film and
we'll just be able to leave and go home
until training camp I mean yeah the team
gets emotionally it builds smile a
little
and how many times you see Bill
Belichick smile gosh I don't remember
one not even one not during that year I
don't I mean bill is just a classic man
I mean Tom humbles a snap and he just
goes rod and everybody looks at him
they're like who's he talking to and
he's like everybody rod in the office
just has to go run down to the goalpost
and run around it and come back see I
love Bill Belichick because I'm never
gonna have to play Bill Belichick you
know what I mean like from the outside
I'm like of course that's what it takes
to win but if I was there I'd be like
know it so now let's get to the second
topic
that was coaches versus star players and
Sims what is it gonna be draft QB oh man
all right I'm just gonna be a talking
about this enough already
no more stuffs happening is it yeah dude
all the time all right Sims which draft
quarterback story line are we gonna talk
about
oh god Arnold a New Yorker so it's just
come out that if Sam darn 'old doesn't
go to the Browns
he's going to g-man the Giants are
taking him at number two this court in a
Matt Miller ro Matt Miller here moocher
podcast I've heard that they they think
he's a lie but Josh Rosen Z the attitude
and I think anything is done flappable
you know way about it I've heard that
rumor I want to say this before we even
get into this yeah we have laughed very
often the last few years at the Giants
inability to keep a secret at all come
draft time right I mean the last few
years we knew they wanted lettered Floyd
right last year we knew they wanted
column a what they'll Conklin Floyd one
who is then that ended up screwing them
and who they end up taking and kid
because of that I can't remember off the
top of my head but you're right we all
knew it was fluid or Conklin when Eric
flowers is that that that was it I know
lash Oh Eli Apple definitely yeah
because you took him over Vernon hard
last year they take last year it was
their first-round pick last year safety
no not landing not my receiver Oh Evan
Engram from Ole Miss yeah we didn't know
that one not that quiet but you're right
there were years before that there was a
little boy it's different this year yeah
what are you noticing different about
the Giants organization and they're
they're kind of like Draft rumors and
stuff that's different than yours pack
yeah I just think it's a more quiet in
general I mean yeah I mean I think we
all can can they're one of those teams
you can draw like conclusions to a
little bit just because of the
positional needs they have within their
football team and the state of their
franchise so I mean again we've talked
about this a lot it's either take their
franchise and set up your court take the
franchise quarterback and set up your
team for the next 10 to 12 years it's
takes a qualm barkley and go we're going
all-in with Eli for one or two more
years right or it's trade down a few
picks and go Quentin Nelson or maybe a
Bradley Chubb whoever was there I think
they would rather go Nelson but yeah cuz
it's interesting as soon as they traded
jpp everybody went and that's Bradley
Chubb going number two but I don't know
if that's it no I don't I don't know
that's this seems to be the first rumor
yes that's come out about the giant
right say I'm darn 'old which is very I
mean it's great that's what they want
that's good good placement of the rumor
because it just hey somebody's probably
like Sam Donald a lot maybe we'll trade
- number two special away always said oh
we're going to take a quarterback at
five now you know people I don't believe
any of that [ __ ] I don't know anything I
want to say this to everybody this is
the worst time of yeah you gotta be
careful now that pro days are done right
there's nothing going on now it's just
people in rooms talking to each other
and then they're going what could we
float out there so really the next three
weeks don't really listen to any of
these rumors
so maybe the real question is what are
the Giants trying to accomplish by
coming out that Sam darn 'old is the guy
they would want at number two if Josh
Allen's going I mean to me in the rumors
I've heard is that they do like Sam
Donald at the quarterback position you
know I don't think he's worthy of that
number to pick now he is young and this
is a good situation that hey you sit
behind you you lie and you get better
and get out of some of those raw you
know issues he has at the position so to
me it's either just like hey Sam Darnell
we like them and they're gonna get a
kind of a temperature gauge from the
city about how they feel with him here
where they're gonna get a team let's
just say like the Buffalo Bills who go
oh damn we really wanted Sam Darla -
what wool trade you are you know I will
trade you three of our top four first
picture but that was another story came
out today that the bills are desperately
trying to trade up into the top five
yeah well I mean mhm I if you're if
you're the Broncos aren't gonna take a
quarterback right the Colts aren't gonna
take a quarterback the Bucs aren't gonna
take a quarterback the Bears aren't
gonna take a quarterback who's nine the
dinars right Niners aren't gonna take a
quarterback the Raiders and take
quarterback right so in my mind you're
kind of battling yourself why not like
you're you're battling a Cardinals or a
Bengals or someone trades I'm not
writing up to try and get it yes but no
one has the ammunition the bills do no
they so I don't understand like trading
up to five doesn't make sense
trading up to two makes sense yes as
you're jumping the other team and that
would be the other thing that I've been
told and again I don't know this for
sure it's not like anybody in Buffalo
told me this but the one thing I have
heard is that they do like Josh Allen
and that they wanted a trade up but
they're not gonna trade up to number two
to get the guy they don't want so
they're getting a wait to kind of hear
from what Cleveland and what way they
are gonna get like I remember when the
Eagles traded up to two and I was
oh no what if the Rams take carson wentz
and then we have jarrett golf you know
but it actually worked out that time
right well I think they knew I think
that was a case where they knew somebody
had told them something or I don't think
they made that trade without knowing
last thing about this if they do draft
Sam darn 'old yeah does it make you look
at the quarterback situation with Eli
like is is this a good situation for Sam
Darnell to enter with who he is
oh it is it definitely is I think it's
oh it's won't it be an ideal situation
again like I said I'm not here to like
crap on Sam darlin cuz he is a top 20
pick no matter what I just don't see the
number one or number two pick type
talent type of thing but this would be
ideal yes because he is raw and he is
young and he is gonna need a little bit
of growing time there and I think this
is a perfect situation where he can fit
in and kind of just take notes from
Shermer and Eli and not be pressured by
the situation quarterback draft stuff
the argument against Josh an argument
against Josh Allen so I went and I was
like I need to argue with Sims ah but
here is I was wondering why are there
some people that are so against Josh
Allen and there are some people that are
so for Josh Allen this to me might be
the most divisive quarterback that we've
covered in a very long time in terms of
the analytics community and the scouting
the GM like going off of measurables and
film category right so here are the two
statistics that I see are most commonly
mentioned the quarterback he goes
against all of the metrics that the
analytics guys are using quarterbacks
chosen in the top 100 since 2005 to the
last 13 years with a completion
percentage below 58 in their last year
Andrew Walter Jake Locker Christian
Hackenberg Connor Cook CJ Beathard
now Mel Kiper comes out and says
completion percentage doesn't matter but
it goes against that statistic right
here's another one
cubase ratings since 97
there have been 27 different
quarterbacks chosen in the top 100 with
a negative cubase rating the most
notable ones in the first round Mark
Sanchez Josh Freeman Kyle Boller Rex
Grossman JP Lossman Patrick Ramsey so
what the analytic community is going we
have these statistics and any time
someone falls in these these are what
they've turned into and every time
they've ended up being right and they're
looking at this guy and they're going
he's got a huge arm we they're they're
going you can say that he didn't have
any talent on this team which makes it
harder to evaluate but they're looking
at all these numbers and they're going
we've never seen a guy be successful
with these statistics so what is your
response to this oh it's just that I
don't even know what the Q rating is q
base right talk about completion
percentage and stuff and I'm gonna
double I'll say my same things I've been
saying all right I mean first of all you
know I hear a lot about oh well you know
turn on the Iowa filmer and we're a turn
on the Oregon film okay I get that yes
they were severely overmatched
I mean severely I mean way worse than
Ohio State over USC or Notre Dame over
USC this is like this is like one
double-a schoolish verse legit Division
One teams right this is a Wyoming team
that probably wasn't as talented as
Carson Wentz's North Dakota State team
with the same coaches right so again the
stats I get it is there some rawness
there yeah the stats aren't gonna people
are gonna love the stats but the offense
doesn't like preclude itself to friendly
quarterback stats right you can watch
Josh Allen and the five games I watched
I think he threw five screens total in
the five games now I could show you
first quarters of the other quarterbacks
where they've shown they thrown five
screens in the first quarter and they're
5 for 5
so the completion percentage
conversation is so stupid to me because
of that
Baker Mayfield's Sam Donald's completion
percentages are so inflated because they
throw so many wide receiver running back
screens behind the line of scrimmage so
are you gonna tell me so that's where
it's probably about an 8 to 10 percent
completion percentage because of that
place so right there oh man yeah he can
throw the ball soon back of the
but then added to this there's more to
it he played in [ __ ] Wyoming what's
it in Wyoming what's the weather there
it's not Southern Cal it's not Oklahoma
it's not Louisville
it's [ __ ] Wyoming I don't know what
the weather's like I mean it's freezing
and it's windy in the game you watch it
the flagpoles are why and I think of
what I think of like Cowboys you think
of like a desert yeah that's not what
it's like up there it's a cowboy of the
desert that bullet
sometimes Melones deserts snow and Nick
here it's [ __ ] freezing okay so yes
you that you taking the elements the
elements the towel level is I mean
that's a real thing when your receivers
can't get open everest that's an issue
when you have the worst pass protection
of all these guys that's an issue and
the offense itself we talked about lack
of the screens I mean most of his throws
other than six yard hitch rats on the
sidelines aren't down the field every
throw is 10 15 20 40 yards down the
field so that would be my argument
so Cubase is also in my mind it's QB a
switch is quarterback adjusted stats and
experience it looks at college
performance experienced and expected
draft position it goes on to say this is
on Football Outsiders usually has
amazing stuff
Cubase QB ace favors quarterbacks
expected to go high in the draft who
also have a relatively long resume of
college success the stats include
completion percentage yards per attempt
and team passing efficiency the numbers
are adjusted for the quality of defenses
that are the team stats there were
chances that we're not talking about the
quarterback we're talking about oh the
offense and then excessive factors in on
the quarterback shoulder it also factors
in the quality of his offensive
teammates so that's why I think Josh
Allen's gonna be very interesting case
sure I go back to that book about what's
it called when I say something and it
impacts you the butterfly effect no
dammit I don't know I can't think about
your life man it was the book it was the
book in which they talked Daryl Morey
talked about DeAndre Jordan how they
missed on the abaya
dammit so we talked about DeAndre Jordan
and it's like all of the statistics
didn't match any of the things they had
in the Jay
but they couldn't factor in that he
didn't like his freshman coach he didn't
like going to class he hated living in
in College Station he didn't want to be
at Texas A&M and he realized that he had
to allow for a little bit of human error
to come in in order to properly evaluate
a player right it can't all be statistic
right and I think that Josh Allen is
gonna be more of the DeAndre Jordan than
of the JP Lowe ceman I just from the
talent that's there it just makes a lot
of sense yes I just wanted to bring up
the statistics that go along with what
the argument is against Josh Allen yeah
right I mean yeah so he took completion
percentage yards per attempt right which
I don't like that either yards for
attempted noise me it's a stupid stat
it's yards for completion that tells you
the story I don't give a damn about
yards per attempt I mean yeah there's a
difference between a guy who throws the
ball 5 yards 20 times in a row and ok
maybe he completes 19 of them and then
there's another guy that throws the ball
20-plus yards 20 times in a row and
maybe he only completes 10 or 12 of them
but his plays are more effective they're
more scary to the defense they make more
pressure on you and they're more capable
of changing the tide of the game plus
yards that do it right all right last
one Lamar Jackson pro day and cam Jordan
alright so yeah alright Lamar Jackson
pro day what you see I saw a lot of the
same things that I saw really this whole
offseason I mean again saw some throws
that I liked certainly but it's raw it's
just him going out there trying to
figure it out and let me just you know
figure it out in my hands so you don't
really even more confident I didn't feel
more confident you know I'll say this
and I like them make my Mayock said this
during the workout he goes this is a
better workout than Teddy Bridgewater
had and that's what I wanted well I was
sitting there going is somebody gonna
say that okay because it was bothering
me he's was infamously but I mean
horrible forgot his gloves because never
worked out the wide receiver I was just
once duck after another like to the
point where you're like damn it totally
changed your thought on the guy
completely so again yes there's things
there but I think the most concerning
thing again is just the fact that he
didn't run the 40 you know again why
why would you not run it I'm not gonna
sit here and go always out of the first
round cuz you didn't run it because like
guys like Eli and Byron Leftwich they
found ways not to run the 42 or find
some way to finagle their time cuz Lamar
could be a 535 or it could be a four or
five five but when you don't run it we
assume you're a four or five five yeah
or that he hasn't been coached well or
whatever it may be right he hasn't put
the time into the maybe the mechanics of
the race but to me I mean again nobody
needs to see Lamar Jackson run when you
can run for 80 yards on Mississippi
State or you can turn the corner on
Derwin James and for the state man you
can effin run that's all there is to so
then why do you need to see it because I
would like to see it just because for
the Lamar Jackson propaganda he needs to
help he need something positive he could
have gone out there run four to nine and
everybody got holy crap I mean man he
really might be Michael Vick I mean he
needs something positive to build on in
this offseason I think that's the sad
thing not from a not from a evaluator
standpoint or a bloviator standpoint I
just wanted to know how fast Lamar
Jackson was that was just for me as a
fan with him running the forty would
have been really just helped the overall
story around him right now but instead
the story is still man know the story
about Lamar Jackson is now his mom is
his agent and no one can get in touch
exactly that's the college story telling
you that right I mean I wasn't telling
you that was an inch now that's that's
where we are and how he's realized it
right because teams were having issues
getting in contact with them not just
michael vick and other people I know but
damn when the teams are having a problem
with getting in contact I've known some
pretty big-time ballers who could not
get in contact with Lamar Jackson this
offseason who's the biggest ball I'm not
gonna tell you so my thing is is how
much does that impact a team if they've
never met a guy well they met him at the
yeah they're gonna meet him but it just
shows you that it's not being as
professionally run as can be but you
know again Lamar Jackson at the end of
the day the film is gonna speak volumes
for him and that's what people are gonna
watch at the end of the day they are
they're gonna look at it you know man
his upside is so phenomenal we're gonna
have to take a chance on them here in
the first round of the draft and I think
there's a number of teams that will do
that the cam Jordan part
well cam Jordan on the NFL Network right
and they were asking him what the Saints
should draft and all that and he says
maybe that tight end maybe but you know
what but I could also see me be doing an
heir apparent sit behind Brees and learn
and then he looked at the camera he goes
any mouthful Mark Jackson and they're
like what you say and he goes nothing
I'm just saying that sheldon Rankin's
went to Louisville that's what I am
Jordan said from the Saints right and it
made me think where do I want Lamar to
go not who should take him where do I
want him to go and I started looking at
all the teams that maybe need a
quarterback that are not in the top five
because I don't think anyone the top
five is taking Lamar or other and it
just doesn't seem like you know they're
not 11 the dolphins 15 the Cardinals 16
the Ravens 17 the Chargers 21 the
bengals 27 the saints 28 the steelers 29
the jaguars
31 the patriots those were the teams
that i wrote down that i went maybe and
then i wrote down their offensive
coordinators because I don't want Lamar
Jackson to go to a guy that's gonna
force him into a system yeah dolphins
have gase I like that I liked it a lot
yeah
Cardinals have Mike McCoy right I like
that - I like McCoy a lot of roll out
offense right play-action roll out
Ravens morning wegg morning wake had a
hell of a year with Mike Vick that one
time Chargers Whisenhunt I was gonna
turn to you on that one I think the the
thing Whisenhunt has it all and I think
the thing you got to think about there
is Anthony Lynn because a run game
coordinator so if you mix the run game
with Lamar right that's where I think
that's where I think they had the great
value in deshaun Watson last year
remember how we talked about that right
so that that's where I get that because
Anthony Lynn's going who Whisenhunt
could get him on the pass game and all
had a few wrinkles the run game and
watch out bengals bill laser which is
like a Chip Kelly yeah which I get it
but I don't want Lamar to go they're
just not my favorite might be the right
team and support system around him
though and the fact that it's close to
Louisville that's where I look at it and
got a good point yeah and you're right
the team around him they're really good
at handling
everybody right uh Saints Sean Payton I
think is my favorite I think I think if
he gets to go to New Orleans and sits
behind Drew Brees right and can get a
year and then Sean Payton in the back of
his mind is building an offense like
that money and Kimora
of course the Jaguars in Hackett would
be amazing
but I think for Lamar right I think the
Saints are the best cuz Sean Payton's
the best of the bunch he is and then 31
Patriots Josh McDaniels I'd lose my [ __ ]
like the Patriots got Lamar Jackson
everyone's gonna go you know I've always
liked Lamar Jackson so I think out of
all of them my only question though
about teams like the Chargers and the
and the Saints and the Jaguars and the
Patriots are those are the teams that
are in the Super Bowl window and to use
a first-round pick on a project
quarterback right on a quarterback that
they need to develop that's not gonna
play right away right I don't know if
that's the best use of your pick
yeah because the Chargers the Chargers
Saints Jags and pat-pat and Piazza yes
can all go for it this year they can but
I also think that a team like the Saints
and Jaguars can afford they can to use a
first-round pick especially because they
have no hopes they really don't Saints
they could use another offensive lineman
they could use a defensive lawyer they
could use a line back whatever you're
right there's no doubt about it there's
a few more needs there and they probably
look at it and go man it's Drew Brees
and his last leg but it could go either
way I would love to see that the Jaguars
one supporters make the most sense for a
number of reasons but just because if
they draft Lamar Jackson right and then
they end up getting rid of the Blake
bortles contract you have the entire
team getting paid because Lamar's a
little rookie deal right
you know that's a good point you're
opening up so much salary office exactly
so where do you want them to go of that
list gosh what's your number one my
number one's the same yeah I think my
number one's the Jags okay yeah what's
your number two my number two would be
the Saints and then who's your number
three I think that my number three is
the Chargers
I think the Chargers would be amazed
what be cool now that you brought up
Anthony
right oh man I know because I don't
think people realize the Anthony Lin is
the reason LeSean McCoy was incredible
and buffering no no no LeSean McCoy is
incredible no matter why but he he had
1500 rushing yards and then he goes
there and unlocks a little bit of Melvin
Gordon towards the end of the year and
all those guys even in the Jets before
that he was phenomenal to start a Kris
Ivory's career all those guys I mean
he's that's what he's known for that's
he's a tough sob yes and he's gonna run
the football and if you had a
quarterback like holy Christ Melvin
Gordon and Ryan all right so we only
have one topic left you don't the rush
in and that is the holdout amigos we
have three guys that are our favorites
and they are all possible to hold out
there's a story about each of them in
the news so Sims reach on in there
and tell us which amigo Oh Delta Aaron
Donald who are the the first amigo Aaron
Donald Aaron Donald is the first amigo
Sims I don't know if you saw it but here
is video of Aaron Donald practicing
working on his hands while a guy is
holding knives Oh nuts you might only
have one nut at that night but he's
holding nice and this is the first
example of whoa big offseason whoa big
offseason Aaron Donald is working out
with knives I mean a little dangerous
why is the guy holding the knives the
one wearing the pads I don't know but
can he wear what if he just was like
holding some like big wooden stick so it
next to that I know we have to have
stitches together do you think they did
it one time or like good we got it for
Instagram now drop those let's just
toast I was thinking like I don't even
think those knives don't look real to me
well they look like big plastic like
Fugazi's like I think like my little boy
has those this is like the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle plastic knives so
you think they're you think they're fake
I thought at first I was like oh wait is
he at the Rams facility is he do
legal work here with coach but then I
ever saw the Pittsburgh thing yeah right
yeah I don't I don't know man especially
when you're waiting to get like a
hundred million dollar contract right I
don't know
training with knives is the smartest
turn my ankle playing basketball hole we
don't know if we can pay you then hey I
lost my right jugular cuz I was doing
some hand work I bled out on the field
for 20 minutes
I should be fine though yeah well no
it's like the Von Miller story of his
crazy workouts where Hugh be climbing
and doing a monkey bar while holding a
lot of weight while someone yells you're
holding children and if you let go they
all die that's a mental thing that is
getting stabbed by a knife is not mental
matt'll make your hands quick I'll tell
you that much
you think I mean yeah yeah I mean I'd
rather my hands be quick than me get hit
I mean this again can't you just say
quicker ie you're right like I said why
can't he just have like a big wooden
stick I don't get that you're gonna take
the opposite side I actually think that
this is why no one else in the league is
as good as Aaron Donna yes because
they're not practicing with spoons while
the rest of the NFL's spooning Aaron
Donald is knifing his way to a new
country hold your applause it wasn't
that great of a point all right back to
it to the other hold out amigos - in
there - levy on bail Le'Veon Bell came
out of them he came out last week after
we did our show and he said that he
wanted Antonio Brown money oh man which
is 17 million dollars a year and I guess
the question I'm gonna ask you is which
players more important to the steelers
levy on Beller Antonio Brown ooh oh I'm
gonna say Le'Veon Bell I just saw and I
don't think it's that crazy Sims I do
think it's crazy because that's just not
the end of the conversation he's gonna
say that he lines up and catches 80
balls a year
he plays wide receiver and running back
yes does Antonio Brown play on
no but no I'm going to play men who
would be better at other person's
position I'm going to play young man go
and go well that's great but I saw two
rookie running backs the supply way is
way more than the demand interval but
how many of those running backs was
amazing Kareem Hunt was amazing before
that of his Jordan Howard Todd Gurley
whatever it may be they're growing on
trees they're running back but I would
also argue right that there's about 15
to 20 wide receivers in every draft
class that stick around the NFL for
years and then there's like five running
backs that make a big name for myself
but you're gonna go those 15 receivers
none of them are Antonio Brown I mean
that's the that's kind of those running
backs how many are 11 Bell well I think
more more are levy than how much more is
Antonio Brown worth than levian I don't
think he's I'm not gonna sit here and
say he's necessarily worth I think you
just have to the worth of the position
in the NFL and what levy I was gonna say
is I play both so shouldn't I get a
little bit of each because of my
versatility you you're saying that Y
receivers are worth more than running
backs I'm telling you that I can play
wide receiver and running back right and
if you won you could have one less guy
on your roster and like a 5th front wide
receiver because you could put me back
out there and throw James Connor in the
backfield if you want to keep the play
action rolling right you could use that
on defense because you can't draft
corners yeah okay so why do I have to
but it's also the most physically
demanding position and men you've
already missed a year and why do I want
to give you that type of long term
security even though you do I just need
three years of 70 I need a three year
fifty-four million dollar deal what do
you think three me three years 54
million seventeen a year fully
guaranteed three years yeah I think it's
just a hair too expensive I'm offended I
know you know I'd love to know I'm going
I'm going somewhere else I just say it's
just it's a little too much man I mean
he can't make 10 million dollars more
than the next running back in football
you are the running back I also I'm just
trying to say Luba we also have to be
realistic and I'd rather see him get a
little bit more long-term security than
just do these franchise tag type deals
so if he wants to do like I don't know I
mean you know I under
stand like you're three years 54 million
whatever it may be
maybe they add a fourth year to that and
they give them a more guaranteed money
up front and make them earn the third
and fourth year gotcha
right what I mean you know what I'm
trying to say like May 26
I know he's got a lot of years left but
again running back for the most part
they can fall apart at 28 29 whatever it
may be so you got to be careful it's
just crazy it's the only position where
I feel like we go sorry because of your
position I can't pay you I know
well it's supply and demand just like
anything else and that's and when guys
like David Johnson are being drafted in
the third and fourth round teams go well
damn and we got you in the seventh round
time out so so then why don't we get
that way Oh Stefon Diggs he was a fifth
round pick up Tom Brady he was a six
round pick I know because you're not
seeing this I mean Brady's okay that's
like one of my receivers go later that's
a change I know but it's not a lot it's
not a ton I think it's far less than the
running back position the elite
receivers that you can go oh like the
Mike Evans of the worlds the Odell
Beckham jr. and Tony O'Brien is really
one of the few katanas later in the
draft that's actually been that good so
I just feel bad for levian because he
wasn't the first round I know it's he
was a second round I'm all for it I hope
he gets it I'm not trying to say I'm
just playing the NFL GM cap to just give
you a few arguments there last jr. the
only reason he's in there so that I can
gloat right because I said last week oh
you did that Odell Beckham once a week
should release a workout video and what
do you know you confused my wife too
he's on the beach in Florida doing a
workout why did I convince Laura you
somewhere it's California there's a
mountain in the background there's no
mountains in Florida so I could Simms is
so good at contacts clues why did I
confuse your wife because she saw it and
she was like wait did Odell tweet at the
podcast she was all confused and I was
like no I think Adams just referring to
Odell's tweet saying he's following
something adam has said on our podcast
yes
so whoever shout-out to Odell's PR
people apparently you know what no not
to be every Odell listens to the podcast
to you out of left Co you're as PR versa
oh no oh stop it no ice no left goes
bleacher report email but if you need
any more advice from us dismiss him I'll
speak some sense into him and then he'll
relay the message this is proof that
Odell listens to the Sims and left go
podcast so Adele you're welcome now if
you want to do it again this week but
here's the best part you know what the
number one comment was under that post
like Jerry Rice keep grinding that's
what happens this is how ridiculous
social media is if Odell continues to
post one video a week people be like man
the Giants are trippin Odell is gonna
kill it next year no matter who he goes
to oh he's in California maybe he's with
Rams players oh man he's grinding now if
Odell posted once a week think about
this if Odell posted once a week a video
of him eating a lollipop oh I guarantee
it off that people would say he's gonna
get fat he's not sticking to his diet
but all he's doing is showing you the
one time in twenty four times seven a
hundred and forty a hundred and forty
eight hours a week that he is eating a
lollipop that will convince people that
he's not caring enough that's why social
media is [ __ ] nuts and everyone
believes it yeah
Aaron Donald may have after that workout
they may have gone ok the knives are
done ok put them down they were
ridiculous but we're thinking of him in
like a butcher like fighting cleavers
and butchering knives and all that one
social media post indicates your entire
offseason yeah that's why when you see a
guy and they're like I love giving back
to charity it's the guys that really
give back to charity don't really post
that they're too busy giving back to
charity but that's why you know you
think social media is ridiculous that's
just I would love if if Odell ate a hot
dog once a week for the whole offseason
people you would read the comments
you've the gym you should be doing
whatever I just think it's funny I know
why it's sites it's crazy
we're in a crazy world we are all right
so Wonderlic scores came out what did
you get on the Wonderlic again 2424 so
your
one point dumber than Baker Mayfield one
point dumber yeah he got 25 rose and got
what Thailand I love that I told you one
point dumber than you went that means he
got yeah Baker got 25 darn 'old got 28
rose and got 29 Alan got 37 Lamar got 13
right how much stock do you put in the
Wonderlic it's not a whole lot I just
not gonna like make any final like
detrimental thing or even a positive
thing to me I mean I'm just not gonna
look at it that way yeah what did you
think of the wonder like when you took I
was surprised I mean Josh Alan that was
a good thing to hear okay great the
Wunderlich it's all over the place first
of all I mean each question gets
progressively harder you get you got 60
questions you got 12 minutes to finish
right and you don't know how many I got
through I probably I think I only got
there like 38 or whatever and obviously
got some wrong with my 23 but like I
told you before I had a team give me an
illegal Wunderlich at the end of my
senior year at Texas he pulled me into a
room and he gave me the Wonderlic and I
got like a 26 or 27 but I got lucky left
go just cuz I knew some of the vocab
words I'm doing one and then when I took
it at the NFL Combine they did not know
so again it's just another piece of
evidence to gather about players people
are gonna look at a little more Jackson
13 and go oh that's not very good and no
it's not the best certainly but it's not
gonna go all he can't learn a playbook
I'll say it one time again Bobby
Petrino's offense is more complicated
than
usc's offense or Oklahoma's offense or a
lot of the offenses in college football
he was completely capable of handling
that so remember I took the right leg
Wonderlic last year and what you get and
I did it in 11 minutes and 52 seconds
and I got a 41 so in the NFL I would be
a freer in generous yep you're a kicker
good job yeah but that's but when I took
it it was like which word is most
similar to magnanimous and I'm like I
don't understand how this would impact a
football yeah right right I know a lot
of players listen you know if Jon eats a
pizza in 8 minutes if he only had four
minutes how much pizza would he eat yeah
like it was stuff like that and I was
like this is like I this is this is who
Adam Lefko is
Adam Lefko only got into college because
of his SATs cuz Adams really asked to
talking third person I'm really good at
standardized tests because I'm very good
at deductive reasoning and so my GPA was
whatever but my SAT was super high yeah
because I'm really good at filling out
bubbles I think some people learn that
way and do that and some people don't
right and I think this goes back to the
reason that I think the test is
ridiculous when it comes to quarterbacks
a coach should cheat should teach their
offense to a quarterback in a way in
which their quarterback can learn itch
they should not teach their offense in a
way that they're used to teaching it
I heard the Chargers were very impressed
with Lamar Jackson's ability to retain
the playbook
oh that sounded like news I haven't
heard it is news there you go break that
out how you like them apples but yes so
that's what I was told that they gave
him a piece of the playbook one night
and then the next night they came
brought him in and studied it with him
and he they were very impressed not
everybody to learn just through vocab or
reading or whatever it is Rob Gronkowski
I can promise you he's not like reading
Aristotle at night but man when he goes
into a meeting rooms and so if it sees a
picture of a play and gets to watch it
on film and maybe gets to walk through
it one time it's in his brain forever
I mean it's he's gonna remember it
forever so the one thing I've never
understood is like they're always
testing him at the board right and there
is like all right so this is Z flat 6 9
4 3 2 slash butthole and then they're
like if I move him there who's there
what happens and I go when are you ever
gonna talk to your quarterback like that
like is that how you teach people things
yeah like no like you're gonna sit there
and and write like you've told the story
about Kyle Shanahan before where he
would send video clips of him explaining
it right you know there's different ways
to teach people things I took a course
in college that said some people are
auditory some people are visual some
people are kinesthetic right like I'm
kinesthetic I have to write things
that's why I do this yeah because once I
write it down I do not forget it right
but if you tell me things you can ask
producer Josh I'm going to ask you five
more time right it's the reason my
girlfriend is getting frustrated yeah
Adam I told you I need to write it down
here's Josh right here are you agree
Josh literally said to me last week I
usually have to tell him things like
eight or nine times five or six it's
eight or nine yeah like last week Josh
was like I was like so when's that
digiday thing he goes I've told you
seven times
Adam had me do a meeting with him to go
over how to use Google Calendar properly
and I set him all up with all the bells
and whistles so he could easily track
and manage his own life and then here we
are he can't I think I might needed to
have that meeting - yeah Josh is Josh is
like next level
Josh is the josh mcdaniels was that it
were you outside listening see today so
I saw somebody in a press conference and
I said then there's Josh look at Josh
vendrick now it wasn't cousins field
gates wasn't filled yeah it's a Scottish
team who was it I saw him that I can't
think of who it was I know I know
I would love Josh have you taken the
mclovin for sure have you taken the
Wonderlic okay I won Josh tickle yeah I
did last year they crushed him see you
Josh see you buddy showing up yeah
thanks for doing it evening the last
thing I want to do before we wrap up is
we never got a chance to talk about two
guys that are most likely to go in the
top ten and that's the linebackers well
let's not do it this way if we were
gonna do this I don't want to talk about
the rest of the linebackers to like at
least talk about the top five or like
you do these two how deep do you want to
go well I mean I think there's I think
we're done for today I know why how long
we've been going I don't an hour and 10
now and 15 no more I don't know things
how long okay so then let's do this
there's three first luron linebackers to
me at this point from what I think save
it okay there's three first-round
linebackers to that you know one that's
unexpected
coming up on Wednesdays podcast on
Wednesdays podcast we're doing this
right we're going to do linebackers okay
we're going to do cornerback okay so
it's gonna be a big Scout day on the
podcast also I am going to be bringing
in the Iowa scouting report from our
friend that drove hours to meet us at
the Super Bowl
right I have his scouting report because
you did John you scouted Josh Jackson
yet from
oh I'm not I mean watch Mara we are
going to I am going to read his one
beforehand his scouting report and we
are going to see on the podcast how he
is as a scout and honestly what I want
and this is from our man Mitch Neeson
men shout out you're the man Mitch to
the listeners out there if you've made
it all the way through this podcast if
you have some scouting reports on some
cornerbacks just start claiming them
just shoot me a tweet or an email don't
send me don't send us Lanzer lion's
copyright I want I want you we're gonna
do the cornerbacks
so who are the cornerbacks that you know
you're going to be watching like ten of
them I mean it's a deep class I just
know right off the bat you know of
course Ward Alexander Jackson the kid
from Central Florida the kid from
Colorado
the kid from Florida yep
the kid from hold on you know I don't
have names and crap yet but there's
about eight um hold on hold on I'll give
him two I'll give them I'll give you the
rest of them here we go who else am I
missing the kid from LSU Dante Jackson
Duke Dawson out
Jair Alexander Isaiah Oliver Mike Hughes
Carlton Davis Josh Jackson
Denzel Ward those are the corners I'm
going to bang out today and today and
tomorrow so if you guys want to send a
paragraph long scouting report when we
go through this I am going to read your
scouting report Sims will give you a
grade of you as a scout and then he will
give his scouting report so if you want
to do this on Twitter go for it
if you want to put it in the reddit sims
and left Co by the way the Renat Sims
and left go says that we need to
rediscover versus lie in debate so we're
gonna do that on Wednesday as well bear
vs. lion have your arguments ready for
lion I love my argument Oh God best guys
send us your scouting reports we love
you a lot I hope you guys enjoyed this
we were gonna be recording again on
Wednesday and next week is jam-packed I
just know that Joe Montana is gonna be
on the podcast
which is gonna be awesome so this one is
for sims peace out homies for fender ik
good evening and for the lef koe man we
say good night for sims and left go
thanks as always subscribe subscribe
subscribe YouTube YouTube YouTube we
love you well aren't you soon